[Music]
oh
d
[Music]
o
all right let's go ahead and open up the
doors to daily with Doc and Becca my
name is Becca dukes and I just want to
welcome everybody who is here live with
us in the zoom room and if you're not
live with us and you would like to be
you are welcome to join us we are at
Daily withth do
zoom.com Wednesday Thursday Friday from
noon to one Pacific time so again that's
daily with do
zoom.com 12 to 1 Pacific time I am
excited to be able to bring to you
information that gives more power to you
as an empowered individual to be able to
make choices in regards to your own
health and also to kind of get a an in
an inside look outside look at some of
the things that maybe going on around
you that you don't realize that are
actually negatively affecting your
health welcome to daily with Doc as part
of an amazing Community we are a
resource for those individuals who are
coaches Health
Advocates
um just people that love to love on
people and show them that there are
other options when it comes to choosing
your health Journey so if somebody
shared this program with you or invited
you to watch this make sure that you get
back with them and thank them for
sharing this information with you and if
you you want to get started it's not if
you're gonna want to get started on what
you hear of in this program so make sure
that you get back with them to get
started as they probably have their own
special way of getting product and we
want to make sure that since they took
the time and cared enough about you that
they also are able to receive a thank
you check for sharing this information
with you and you can do it too so I love
the fact fact that thank you checks are
a way that the company that Dr wallik
started like 27 28 years ago called
young
jevity thanks their field and the crew
people who are part of this Crusade for
sharing the
information so if you were to refer
somebody to a movie or your favorite
hair product do you get a thank you
check I never have but well until to now
because I do have my favorite hair
product within this company and they
send me a thank you check for referring
so I love thank you checks um and it is
a way that helps pay for my own product
also helps pay for for my home and this
there is no uh he income claim here
folks
but we have a lot that we can do as an
empowered individual to not only help
ourselves but help our communities and
then together we can help the world find
a better health Journey so hold on and
get ready because
today we are going to be talking about
something that you know when you hear
about liver problems most of the time
you relate that to alcohol consumption
or some type of
chemical interface well not always and
we have with us the one and only who is
one of the founding fathers of the
science of epigenetics the science that
proves the genetic theory of disease
transmission to be incorrect not genetic
and he is also one of the or the person
who found the first nonhuman case of
cystic fibrosis in a reesei monkey and
he proved that it was not hereditary or
genetic he also proved that it was a
nutritional
deficiency so if you know anybody that
has little ones or even have been able
to grow up into adulthood that are
dealing with that condition of cystic
fibrosis you definitely want to share
this information and this doctor and
this program with them as well because
there are things that we as individuals
can do to help ourselves so without
further Ado it is my honor and privilege
to bring to the screen with me Doctor
Joel wallik in his young eight decades
plus as he's bringing his knowledge and
wisdom with almost 32,000 autopsies
whether he was very instrumental in the
autopsy
himself or in the review of them and
determining and connecting those dots as
to when something was
missing which disease was occurring so
Dr Wall hello and welcome to daily with
Doc well thank you so much Becca Becca
thank you team we appreciate everybody's
efforts the world needs us now more than
ever so I appreciate everything
everybody's
doing well Dr wck it's because of you
that I'm able to do this and I wouldn't
be able to do this if I hadn't been able
to to regain my own health
from a place physically mentally and
emotionally that I didn't know that I
was going to be able to make it out of
so thankful to you and to those who put
you on the radio because that's where we
initially heard about you I want to do a
shout out as we do have Dave Michaels
with ksco here continuing to broadcast
this program out on the airw so we want
to say hello to our radio audience we
also want to say hi to those who are
watching us out on YouTube and Rumble
and um Amazon TV Amazon music podcasts
we have are on so many different
channels Dr W like I can't even remember
them
all to to but hey folks if you're
watching us listening to us you know
where you're at let us know where you're
at so there's a way to put a comment in
there make sure you send us a comment I
want to thank those who do send those
comments I do see them I also um want to
encourage you to
subscribe and also share information
that you hear about on our program with
those that you know and love as well
well Dr wellik we had an interesting
topic come up um from from one of our
viewers wanting to know about the liver
and I know there's therosis of the liver
but there's fatty
liver does it always have to be that the
liver has issues if you have a high
chemical com uh intake or alcohol
intake we have to appreciate the liver
has over 50 different functions it um is
your protector against infectious bugs
it's your protector against poisons um
it's your to protect your against
nutritional deficiencies because you
store nutrients in the liver when you
have them excess you store them in the
liver and you can call them out of the
liver when you need them because you're
not don't have your diet that week okay
and so liver has a huge huge in arous
function
and you know right now um one of the the
main focuses is on something that
doctors incorrectly think is new or the
metabolic syndrome and I'm the guy who
got rid of as you say CIS rosis very
very proud of that I got rid of muscular
distrophy
Jerry's kids got rid of that disease I
got rid of s death syndrome where the
doctors thought the babies were being
laid on by their mothers and suffocated
all three of those are just simple
nutritional efficien diseases and
there's hundreds of them nutritional
deficient diseases that we have and of
course they've been identified and
actually written up in the book
epigenetics there you go
and um and also in the book rare Rin
cures in the book rare cures I don't
know if you have that one you do okay
good okay and these two books plus let's
play doctor and the Wallock Revolution
those four books cover the metabolic
syndrome cover all these horrible
nutritional deficiency diseases because
this is where I spent most of my
professional life working on these
things and published we're we're going
for I don't know the 35th book here
coming up 25 doc oh 25 not still pretty
good for a young guy okay yeah okay 25
Books Okay and most authors they do two
or three books and they think they're
doing good which is true but we're we're
pushing 25 so we're very proud and very
happy to be in that that area now we do
want to uh just do a quick review here
of um the metabol syndrome now the
metabolic syndrome covers a vast
territory it covers 25% of the American
population are negatively impacted by
the metabolic syndrome 25% of Americans
and there's a very specific um what
should I say ratio amongst the the uh
racial and um ethnic communities because
they're still eating their Foods or
their recipes from where they came from
from 10 15 20 30 years ago but the
nutrition are not there you have to
appreciate minerals for
instance this 2third of the 90 essential
nutrients 60 essential minerals
okay
um are there and we've been using them
for our health for over 3,000 years now
nutritional minerals do not occur in a
uniform blanket around the cust of the
earth they occur in veins like gold and
silver
and when we went to electricity in 1882
it got worse because we were getting our
minerals our nutritional minerals From
the Ashes of wood ashes and coal ashes
which we've been using for cooking and
um warmth and all that kind of stuff and
we went to electricity we lost our
source of nutritional minerals that we
had been using for over 3,000 years we
had all these diseases pop up and it
drove the Doctors medical doctors into a
frenzy because now they had all these
patients they didn't have before for
okay and so when you look at them we're
talking about um let's see here now
we're talking about the metabolic
syndrome and uh type two diabetes is a
big factor there type two diabetes we
also have um liver issues as you were
pointing out we have triglycerides which
kind of touch on the liver thing okay
stroke uh hyper thyroidism high thyroid
drives you crazy okay and low thyroid
which drives you crazier high blood
pressure
diabetes
um let's see here I think those are the
sort of thing plus so many birth effects
so many birth defs and these are of
course in these four books which I'm
hoping that everybody will get and use
as a reference you look it up in in the
indexes of these books and It'll point
you to those diseases
and tell you which ones you need which
nutrients you need to reverse them okay
none of these are genetic I'll repeat
that none of these are genetic all
diseases said to be genetic or not there
are no such things as genetic
diseases that was just sort of the
fallback position so doctor didn't have
to say we don't know what it is okay and
um um osteoporosis arthritis uh
cardiomyopathy um let's see see here
blood pressure we already talked about
that liver disease of all
kinds um triglycerides elevated stroke
diabetes I think we're covering the
territory here okay and the books which
I just showed you those four
books it has all the answers in those
four books if everybody would get those
four
books okay let's play doctor the wallet
Revolution epigenetics and rare Urban
cures
and you just look up the problem in the
index it tells you what page to go to go
to and it tells you what caused it how
to reverse it and how to cure it I mean
why would you not want those four books
right now there's so much big stuff
going on because of the uh terrible
terrible terrible stuff going on from
the metabolic okay metabolic um syndrome
and so this is not difficult it's kind
of like there's so many of these famous
people in these books having their
little comments before the chapter and
they
say um you know why why is the healthc
care profession so ignorant of the truth
when it's been proven over and over and
over and published over and over and
over and so all these famous people that
we've highlighted in these books
epigenetics rarest men cures
um let's play doctor the wall of
Revolution it covers all of these
diseases and
manifestations okay of the metabolic
syndrome and we have so many examples
where people have had the issues for 25
years and in two weeks time is
gone well for the most part though Dr W
like it takes longer than two weeks well
that's true maybe three weeks for the
most
part well no DOC come on we don't want
to overd
deliver I mean
overpromise because there are things
within the body dock that it does take
time for the body to utilize the
nutrition that it needs because it's
been starving so long to get on the
rails yeah to get back on the
rails and I just want to add in that
this program is not meant to take the
place of
your primary Comm to treat diagnose or
cure any disease but when you give the
body what it needs the body itself can
do some amazing things and I know and I
want to do a shout out pharmacist Ben
does not like that disclaimer he's here
with us so I just wanted to say hi
pharmacist Ben we'll have you on
tomorrow so excited to have you with us
tomorrow um but Dr W like when we're
looking at the liver okay so you
mentioned the the overlap the common
symptoms between metabolic syndrome and
liver conditions okay so there's fatty
liver and there's therosis of the
liver what's the
difference okay well they're both caused
by the same basic things nutritional
deficiencies and
toxins okay the liver is sort of like a
filter everything that comes in in the
bloodstream whether it's you know
uh from your stomach or is from
breathing or blood vessels wherever
wherever the this your nutrients or
chemicals
or um wherever it's coming from it it
all goes through the liver the liver is
a tremendous function okay it also has a
gallbladder produced the liver produces
B which helps you absorb essential fatty
acids and fat soluable vitamins if your
liver is not working you can take five
pounds of fat Sal vitamins a day you're
not going to absorb them because you
have to be able to absorb those fats and
the fat Salo vitamins okay and so the
liver is extremely important again over
50 different things that it's
responsible for and so it requires the
90 essential nutrients just like your
heart your lungs your kidneys and so
forth
and you'll see as you go through these
books Let's play Dr the W Revolution
epigenetics rare rare Urban Cur you go
through
there in every case we're talking about
some of the things that the liver are
responsible
for and you have to take good care of it
the liver needs 90 essential nutrients
or some of the nutrients that requires
more of one of my favorite things for
the liver is selenium
selenium reduces your risk of cancer
including in the liver selenium
makes all of the cells in in the liver
function properly including the cells
that make the bile to help you absorb
the fat cable vitamins they're all sort
of intertwined here okay and it's not
complicated but it is
required okay it is required so that if
you're missing something you get a skin
problem you get a lung problem you get
bone marrow problems um you get blood
sugar problems your thyroid isn't
working and these can all be related
to what's going on with and without the
thyroid and with and without the liver
with and without the kidneys with with
and without the heart and so and with
without the intestines and so people are
still responsible for staying away from
the bad foods even if you're
supplementing okay if you want to get
the full value of what you're
supplementing was you got to stay away
from the wheat brought ran oats and
buckwheat because they actually kill the
Villi in your intestines okay the Villi
quadruple your surface area for
absorption and they secrete digestive
enzymes and so
forth and so your Villi are very
important but when you eat gluten we'd
brother around oats and
buckwheat um guess what those Villi die
and so now instead of looking like a
shag rug your int looks like a glass top
on a table okay or a glass tube
in right and you've also you know
referenced the water hose you know a lot
of people know what a water hose looks
like and it's very smooth on the
inside so you had mentioned something
that I want to point out
if we put something in our mouth or we
inject something into our body or it
absorbs into the skin they all
eventually go through the liver it is
correct so the liver is like a filter Li
filters things it sort of is the
gatekeeper so to speak oh you go over
here oh you go there you stop down here
I want you to get stay here in the liver
so we can start building more um
reserves of this particular nutrient
okay and so the liver makes all those
decisions on each nutrient that comes
through it's going through um
the uh large veins and of course the
arteries
come from the heart um down the aarta
and split off into the hepatic arteries
and hepatic veins and all that kind of
stuff and hepatic refers to liver that's
correct hepatitis viral
infections you can also have a hepati is
not infectious you get an irritation
hepatitis because you're eating poisons
or you know like alcohol and that kind
of stuff drinking
poisons and so that can cause a
hepatitis that is not due to an
infection okay the liver is very
susceptible to
poisonous things that you take in
through the skin through your lungs
through your um mouth through your
digestive system through your blood
vessels so your liver is really um very
important in um providing a
screen guess that's where I looking for
providing a
screen to protect you from bad things
that other organs just shrug their
shoulders say I don't I don't recognize
this one and it can kill you but the
liver recognizes it well and you've also
mentioned how it takes the good
cholesterol and converts it into the raw
material that's needed to protect the
brain brain for the white matter of the
brain SM in the brain yeah the liver
converts cholesterol which is an
essential
nutrient cholesterol is an essential
nutrient it's not a poison it only
becomes a poison when you fry
it okay so why frying why why would
frying change that because
frying
oxidize because cholesterol is kind of a
liver excuse me
um fatty acid stuff okay and so you fry
a of fat yeah when you when you fry fats
even cholesterol it turns into something
bad from something good fats are
essential um
cholesterol
uh is the basic factor of female
hormones cholesterol is a basic factor
of male hormones and so if you're
getting on all these injections by the
doctors and pills by the doctors to
eliminate your cholesterol because he's
well cholesterol is bad you glog your
arteries you might as
well go to religions that
have a priesthoods and and
um you know what becoming celibate yeah
celibate that's where I'm looking for
okay well you know that is for some
people um and that that can be a choice
but then sometimes you get forced into
that because things don't work because
you're not getting the nutrition that
your body needs in order for everything
to function properly is that what I'm
hearing yes you're getting
misinformation and of course the medical
system long long long long has been a
source of misinformation there are no
genetically transmitted
diseases blood pressure is not genetic
diabetes is not genetic heart disease is
not
genetic asthma is not gen genetic
um gastric ulcers are not
genetic I can go on and on and on there
are no genetically transmitted
diseases all right well thank you so
much for that intro to the liver the
importance of the liver and Dr wck so
what we eat plays a big factor into the
health of our
liver correct yeah correct and of course
it's our health
also and so with go ahead you had
mentioned you know diabetes being a a
symptom of or associated with liver
disease but there's also fatigue nausea
um diarrhea all these different symptoms
that can be related to other things and
maybe you know connected with other
different poor health conditions but
then when it comes down to to it it may
just be the liver which even if you've
got 25% of your liver functioning it's
possible through through my research
that the liver itself can restore itself
with the right in right ingredients and
eliminating the wrong stuff that is
correct the liver has an enormous power
to maintain and repair
itself and it's the only organ in the
body that can do that that is
correct that's awesome Dr wallik thank
you thank you thank you um so I have
here in the chat I've got Dusty saying
18 months post liver transplant and have
had very distended abdomen it's been on
the 90 for about two months um it's been
getting abdominal area drained every 10
days so was was
Dusty diagnosed with um
well apparently Dusty had a or somebody
Dusty knows had a liver
transplant um and has a distended
abdomen and has to have fluid drains
from the abdominal area every 10 days so
if you've had a transplant Dr wallik
would nutrients help because I know that
they have like anti-rejection
drugs and stuff that are given to people
who have transplant
if you're building your own immune
[Music]
system that's not enough that's not
enough because when you're talking about
um transplants you're talking about the
drugs they use to reduce the bodies
wanting to attack this foreign object
because it's got the it's got the
identification of somebody else so
they're sticking a liver in you and your
body says oh my gosh what is this doing
here and so it sends everything body to
go kill the liver because it's not
you right it's somebody else it's
somebody else and so your body is trying
to defend itself and so this is why we
have so many problems with transplants
particularly the liver the
liver has so many functions
um with blood storage of
nutrients
digestion
immune
system there's no other organ that has
all those functions like the liver
has so it's pretty important to take
care of it folks that's what I'm hearing
yes well Dr wck we have hands up and I
just want to thank everybody even those
and it was brought to my attention of
course we don't want to miss Brion we
don't want to miss Spotify thank you AJ
for putting that up there
um Dr well we have hands up and we just
want to remind people that if somebody
shared this program with you make sure
that you get back with them and tell
them thank you for sharing the program
with them with you and if there are
things that are mentioned in this
program or any of our programs and
broadcasts that you want to implement
into your own diet and supplementation
program also make sure that you're
getting back with the person that shared
program with you if there is no one to
thank you are more than welcome to go to
daily withth
do.com we do have replays of our
previous program including newsletters
or news articles that help to support
your journey in choosing things to
improve your health we also have a call
team this call team is available for
those who have never tried the
youngevity products you've not spoken to
anybody
about Dr Wallock or the youngevity
products I have a call team there at 855
3377 again that's 855
3377 and if you have questions that you
would like to get answers and whether we
talk reply with the answer to your
question or bring it on to the show you
may submit Those Questions by going or
sending an email to rather questions
dawid
do.com that's questions dawid
do.com and if you'd like more
information about how you too can join
us on this
Crusade info dawid
do.com info@ dawid
do.com all right doc let's get to some
questions the first one we're going to
ask Cheryl to unmute mute hello Cheryl
go ahead and unmute
yourself hello hello
Cheryl NOP all right she's not unmuting
herself at the moment so let's go right
over to Kathy Kathy go ahead and unmute
yourself hi hi my name is Kathy Dar
welcome back welcome back I messed up so
I can start all over again I just want
to know what list can I um the kidney
list you tell me about
it well can what all all stuff I
need all right well Dr W Kathy is on
dialysis she is just under a 100
pounds and you have high blood pressure
Kathy no but my sister people telling me
there's no way I can get get off of
dialysis once I once I on
dialysis no doctor can tell me I can get
I can get off of it I stay let's see
let's see what happens here um basically
what you want to do is avoid all the bad
foods that gets you in trouble whether
you have kidney problems or liver
problems or heart problems or not get
rid of the bad foods no fried foods no
processed Meats no oils no glutens no
wheat no R oats no buck wheat no sugar
no carbon drinks even the do ones need
to go and 100 pounds I want you to have
one healthy brain and heart pack per
month take a half those everything a
breakfast have those dinner time okay
and then I want you to take
the the ultimate daily classic tablets
ultimate daily classic tablets I want
you to take at your weight I want you to
take U two three times a day two at
breakfast two at lunch two at dinner
time and it might be like a bottle and a
half
a month of the ultimate daily classic
tablets that's going to help you with
kidney function um and it's going to
surprise the dialysis technicians
because you're going to show Improvement
okay we have so many people who have
been on dialysis and they get on the
ultimate daily classic tablets but this
is something you're goingon to have to
stay on forever you cannot just say okay
I'm doing better now I'll just drop that
well then within a month you'll be in
trouble again and
sometimes you get in trouble you don't
get out of trouble okay and so it's to
I've been taking
supplements and I have witnesses
including Becca I I take hundreds of
supplements every day okay I've been
doing this for since I was nine years
old since I was nine years old okay in a
couple of weeks here I'm going to be
85 okay and it's one of those things
where
um this is unimpeachable unimpeachable
this is nobody I don't care how many
medical doctors there are how many
pH degree people there are how many
nurses there are how many scientists
there are they cannot deny the results
of all these thousands of studies that
have been done by many many people not
just me by myself but many people
showing the same thing over and over and
over so when you get on this you got to
stay on it you can't say okay things are
looking good I can go back to my old
ways no no no don't do that and that's
why you get in trouble
again
okay okay thank you're bet let's hear
from every couple of weeks
Kathy okay so smoothies and GRE drinks
is
okay as long as long as you're sticking
with the Good Foods list in those in
those groups and then uh youngevity has
some chle meal replacement shakes they
have even a vegan vegetarian friendly
protein shake that they're gluten-free
and they go in line with Dr Wall's Good
Foods bad foods list so you can find
those as well um with your independent
coach or on daily with doc.com okay I
had to order as so
because a lot of stuff happened like
that get all all all the stuff again
because my niece I I move she didn't get
the my stuff with me and I lost
everything so oh that's too bad but
we're glad you found us again and you
can get back on track all right okay
thank you very much thank you guys
you're you know how to get hold of me
yes I do thank you
all right thank you Dr wallik and let's
try Cheryl again Cheryl do you get a
little popup there we go oh
good this is the first time I've been on
your on your Zoom
so welcome Cheryl okay I've got a dog
question for Dr
wallik go for it okay um I have a friend
who's lived in three different states
with her king shepherd and she's been in
South Dakota Iowa and and Arizona and
her dog has had no problems being in the
snow and going on Hikes and walks and
now she has moved to Haley Idaho and
since it snowed after that she noticed a
soar on his on his back paw and she
wrapped it up and overnight he chewed
his whole back pad off and she has been
told by vets to keep him in Boots and
use something called muser secret to
toughen his paws up with they are not
healing up and she is wondering what's
causing
this okay now what we don't know the dog
is being fed well the dog needs to be
fed a high quality I'd go with a high
quality canned dog food because we don't
need risk of getting gluten in dry dog
food okay very high quality canned dog
food and it'll tell you how much of that
canned dog food per pound or per 10
pounds of body weight okay and then um
we have uh let's see
here what's that one we have for dogs
and cats Becca start with an
aex Dr wck arrod de okay
AR and so AR arthr deex and so in
addition to the canned dog food you want
to get the Arthur deex and give two
daily doses of arthr deex to the dog and
it stimulates healing okay it has all
these extra nutrients in there that that
are particularly useful in healing now
we keep Arthur deck in the house even
though we don't have any dogs or cats
here because if there's ever a time when
because of shipping or lack of
ingredients the
company would have a problem with
getting the products to us I'll eat the
Arthur deex okay because it's so good
and so um wide in the number of
nutrients it has um you know wouldn't
want to take I take B vitamins well
that's not enough okay you need to take
all 90 essential nutrients and so that's
why I like the arthr deex even for
humans as a as a you know mergin Z
Resort kind of thing okay so yeah the
arth deex and um
um let's see here oh I'd also go with
the collagen okay the glucogel the
glucogel the dog can have three of those
I go with three twice a day the glucogel
capsules and that will help REO collagen
in the joints you know like the um
cartilage and the joints and the skin
and the pads on the feet and so it's
probably missing the raw materials in
the collagen because you know when a
when a coyote or wolf or wild dog eats
an animal that catches it eats the skin
it eats the bones it eats the ligaments
and tendons as well as the sakes okay
and you know it's one of those things
where human beings well I'm a human I
don't need bones they used to they used
to use bones bone broth for thousands of
years they knew that if they drank that
bone broth whatever was in it which was
the minerals from the bones would
rebuild their knees and hips and feet
and ankles and shoulders and back and so
forth and that's why I came up with a
gluca gel because there were less and
less people living on the farm they
didn't have access
to you know Slaughter an animal on the
farm and then they could do their own um
boiling the the Bony Meats to make um
bone broth they didn't need to worry
about bone broth anymore because now we
have oh the arthr deex okay so I hope
that that helps out where do you get the
arthr deex Well from youngevity okay yes
so that is a product in the youngevity
line um one more thing that I would like
to add to that Dr wallik um the arthr
deex also has enzymes to be able to
break down food for for the animals and
I have uh clients that give it to their
Birds also takes just a little bit but
there is also a product called perpetual
and Perpetual plus they add in
antioxidants Perpetual plus also
includes the i26 to help for our pets as
well in a tasty chewable for
them so arthria and then Dr wallik
mentioned the gluc gel or the collagen
that can be used for healthy bones and
joints for them MSM that can be used for
joints and bones
and yeah there's reason and Perpetual so
there's there's no reason that our pets
can't be as healthy as we are and pet
parents don't get to take care of
yourself because I know a lot of pet
parents that take care of their pets
better than they take care of
themselves so thank you Cheryl for
bringing that question thank you very
much this is the first time I've been
here so I'm really
excited welcome welcome welcome you're
also a new coach with the coaching
program so we're
excited looking forward to that
too yes ma'am thank you so much
oh Dr W I have a question from Rebecca
she has been losing weight not me
Rebecca another Rebecca um and she just
had an appointment and the doctor is
saying that her right arm and right hip
will eventually need surgery she doesn't
want to have hip replacement in or arm
surgery so she's very upset when the
doctor told her this she wants to know
what she can do to prevent future
Replacements now she she's 53 years old
128 pounds at 5
foot6 okay and we'll assume that she
doesn't have any anemia and high
pressure and diabetes and all that kind
of stuff right does not have any high
blood pressure that is correct um no no
blood sugar issues as well okay good
okay so get rid of all the bad foods no
fried foods no processed Meats no oils
no gluten no wheat po oats no buckwheat
no sugar no carbon drinks you the diet
ones got to go and then 128 pounds i'
have her take um because of this issue
um I started out with um if finances are
not a problem I'd go with two healthy
brain and heart packs it right on the
border okay of two if if she can only
afford one that's okay that's a place to
start um but she needs two servings a
day either two half servings or two full
servings of the
um uh let's see here the healthy brain
and heart pack okay go with the healthy
brain and heart pack then I would also
go with the glucogel I'd go with three
glucogel three times a day if she's at
that point where the doctors are wanting
to do shoulder replacement and hip
replacement I'd go with three glucogel
capsules at breakfast lunch and dinner
so she'll go through two bottles a month
of the
glucogel okay and um let's see here um I
would also have her take
the CM cream she can put the CM cream on
her shoulder on her knees and her hips
her elbows any place her neck any place
she's got pain and the odds are she's
got other stuff going on here because
when you have that much osteoporosis and
arthritis in your large joints like your
knees and your hips and shoulders and
that kind of stuff you also have
osteoprosis of the skull and she may
have ringing in the ear she may have
balance problems she may have a loss of
sense of taste she may be losing her
vision you know all all these kind of
things wouldn't hurt for her to get the
book um see here it's all in your head
and the CD that goes along with it
because the CD covers the spinal cord
which is something that may be
afflicting her also okay all right thank
you so much for that Dr wck and next
let's go over to nissum and as nissam is
unmuting I just want to invite all of
you to our coaching opportunity meeting
that we have going on
today April 4th at 2 o'clock Pacific
time so that is 5 o'clock Eastern time
you can go to iwh
zoom.com and let them know that the
daily with Doc team sent you for more
information on that you may also call
our call team at 855 949
3377 and that is an opportunity for
those who whether they want to be a
coach or just get information for
themselves because they love knowledge
it is available to everybody and there's
a special that is available for those
who attend to receive the course at 50%
off so that's only like
$73.50
for whole wealth of information and
knowledge and become a certified
holistic health
coach
Nissim how are you today welcome
hello doctor yes how can we help you I
have few very quick questions I started
using your products about two weeks ago
uh and I noticed that sorry for the
graphics here the color of my urine
turned um yellowish greenish almost
chatus in color whereas before it was
clear no no color at all I thought it
might have to do with the minerals but I
wasn't sure if this is so if this is
normal or not I wanted to check that
okay well it's not unusual when you take
supps to have yellow urine okay um it's
one of those things where your liver is
involved here okay because your liver
helps you absorb all these nutrients
that are in the supplements and the
liver when it gets more nutrition kicks
out more bile and what color is bile uh
yellow so the more bile you have
released by the liver into your
bloodstream the more yellow your urine
becomes it's actually more greenish even
is that still the same answer
same answer okay good uh second thing
it's about sugary food you you recommend
not eating which I understand but what
about natural sugar such as honey or or
let's say orange juice or maple syrup is
that you recommend stay off of those too
yeah of course we we use honey in the
house we use maple syrup we use um let's
see here we use apples we use oranges we
use
um um berries and so sugar in of itself
is not bad if you're taking all the 90
essential nutrients so that your kidneys
and your your bladder your um
liver um your intestines every your
pancreas everything can function
properly and also um you need to make
sure that you're um getting all the
minerals okay the 90 essential minerals
and this is why we have the healthy
blood sugar pack okay the healthy blood
sugar pack um is our uh
ultimate what should I say
our 90 essential nutrients plus the
sweeties the 90 essential nutrients plus
the sweeties okay that's the healthy
blood sugar
pack and uh gosh and I've been taking
those for I don't know 30 30 40 years
and um again I'm be in a couple of
months and don't have any trace of
diabetes although my urine does come to
be more yellow sometimes in others it
depending depending on what I'm eating
and what it does and talks to the liver
and the liver releases more bile to help
you absorb um essential fatty acids fats
H vitamins and so that's just a signal
that you that your liver is functioning
doing its job and getting that bile out
there to help absorb the good
stuff okay good and final question is
for me um about raw eggs at least for I
somehow
remember being told to be careful from
you know eating raw eggs or when I
handle raw eggs it could be you know
wash your hands so there's no bacteria
or something uh that you should I mean
you should be aware of that but yet I
know that you you're I think you
recommended or even pharmacist Ben in
one of his videos said it's okay to to
eat Ro eggs so I'm a little confused
about that if you can okay well
basically again you know back when I was
wrestling and playing football and all
that kind of stuff I'd eat to three raw
eggs you know crack them open and and
trying and intimidate the the guys in
the other team I just go ahead and
eating those raw eggs and everything but
if you have plenty of stomach acid if
there's any bugs in there the stomach
acid will kill them but there's nothing
wrong right now I'm eating three eggs
twice a day and we put the
um um let see here in the eggs we go
ahead and you know cook them in butter
not margarine or Oils cook them in
butter soft
scrambled uh okay soft scrambled and
butter and then I'll have either a steak
or a lamb chop or something with it
maybe some salmon um I'll have um rice
that's my carbohydrate primary
carbohydrate is rice I have rice two
three times a day okay so I'm living
like an Asian because the Asians outlive
us by about 10 12 15 years so if that's
what they eat and they live 10 12 15
years longer than us why would you not
eat rice okay but you do have to
remember that the rice is going to have
different minerals in it depending on
where that Rice was grown so you still
have to supplement with all the 90 sens
of nutrients because the um rice grown
in
um Oriental countries are getting
different levels of minerals based on
whether there's a
volcano whether there's
um what
um minerals coming down in the water
from the mountains and and um glacial
milk they call it because it looks like
milk it's white because of the ground up
minerals okay so um this you look at the
hunas they live to be 20 we're Americans
we spend millions of dollars on medical
doctors each year the hunzas don't even
have one medical doctor in hza they live
be
120 and we have all these medical
doctors and our we ranked 47th in the
world the top 100 countries we list 47th
in longevity okay there's 53 other
countries whose peoples live longer than
we do even though we have all these
wonderful doctors because doctors oh
don't don't take any vitamins and
minerals don't waste your money just
well you get everything you need that's
absolutely positively not true you
cannot eat well and get everything you
need
anymore this is thank you very much okay
all right thank you so much niss for
joining us here and let's go over to one
of my well I have lots of friends but
one of my friends Dr well you know his
name Dave Michaels welcome Dave Michaels
go ahead and unmute yourself and what
question are you bringing and I'm gonna
assume from our radio audience uh yes
Rebecca I don't know if you can hear me
or not can you yes okay um hello doc my
question is about hearing loss one of my
clients came by and asked what would Dr
wallik recommend for somebody who is
losing their hearing okay they need to
get the book it's all in your head
there's 12 pairs of cranial nerves okay
including the eighth cranial nerve which
deals with with hearing and that sort of
stuff you need to ask her or him if he's
got um he or she's got any ringing in
the ears or balance problems as well as
hearing loss okay and this is
osteoporosis skull squeezing the eighth
cranial nerve I think it's chapter nine
if he goes over that in that book every
chapter goes for one and is heavy
description of the normal function of
and the diseases of the 12 pairs of
cranial nerves so each chapter is one
cranial nerve okay and then we have a CD
that goes along with about the same tile
it's all in your head uh goes into all
the disease that occur when the spinal
cord is being squeezed coming out of the
back of the skull so it'll freak you out
on page six it'll show you a normal
human skull which is a quarter of an
inch thick it'll show you one that has
osteoporosis as a skull it's an inch and
a half to two inches thick and all the
tunnels which the nerves are coming from
from the brain uh through the skull to
the outside where they do their
function they lose 85 to 95% of the
internal volume putting pressure on
these nerves and depending on which
nerve you're talking about okay and in
this book you will see what what disease
they get when that particular nerve gets
squeezed okay but it's all reversible we
have so many people have gone to experts
and they get hearing aids they do
surgeries they do this this and that and
the other they're missing it by a
million miles because they're treating
the symptoms as opposed to getting rid
of the problem which is the osteoprosis
go squeezing the cranial nerves okay
okay okay thank you very much Dr Wallock
hey you bet thank you for calling and
you know let you know call us in a
couple of weeks and a couple of months
and let us have some
feedback thank you all right thank you
so much Dave and Dr wellik we've got a
question that come came in about a dog
so a two-year-old dog has been leaking
urine on my bed at night while she
sleeps any ideas what could the issue be
the dog is about 35 pounds Dr wallik and
only two years
old okay so we don't know what is being
fed is it being fed a complete dog food
or is it being fed table
scraps could that all plays into it huh
because it could have um uh blood sugar
problems okay could have blood sugar
problems could have osteoprosis to the
skull um again squeezing that eighth
cranial
nerve all right and it be like urinary
tract infection either also it could be
but why would urinate in the bed at
night only kind of thing that doesn't
make
sense well if the bed that might be the
only time she actually realizes that
it's
leaking so what would you recommend doc
well again the Arthur
deex and the minerals you know an ounce
of the plant derived minerals and every
pint of water in the in the drinking
bowl or the water bowl um and um get
those minerals into the the body and it
wouldn't hurt to throw in
the ultimate daily classic tablets it's
good for the uh function of the kidneys
it's good for the function of the
arteries is good for function of blood
pressure and blood
flow ultimate daily classic tablets I
love that product and at 20 pounds one
per day should be sufficient what
shouldn't it yeah you start out with one
and if you get a little bit of benefit
then go to two but if you get no benefit
go to
three all right thank you so much Dr
wallik and let's move over to TC TC go
ahead and unmute yourself as you're the
last caller for
today I hope my connection's stable my
internet's going in and out so I hope I
don't lose you but I called uh three
weeks ago and uh told you about my
mother who's 94 years old had
osteoporosis and a blood clot and you
told me to give her the Bone and Joint
pack rebound the daily classic tablet
and the vitamin D3 and U I've been doing
that uh but she's been like sluggish and
lying around a lot and and uh she
wouldn't get up to go to the toilet that
much but once in a while when she did I
asked her if she took them all she said
she took them but sometimes I saw some
of the tablets and the bed and the the
drinks she sometimes drinks at all but
not all of it uh she says it's kind of
sweet but anyways um we had to have her
go into the hospital her doctor wanted
her get checked to see if she needed a
nurse or rehab and uh they found that
her calcium was high uh two months ago
was 130 but this time it was
270 and her electrolytes were low and
they found some calcified nodes in her
neck and uh she did have a kidney
problem uh in the past so I guess I
don't know what my question is but I I
guess what I'm getting at is because of
the calcium I know that the supplements
have about 1,900 milligrams of calcium
and I guess when if and when she can get
out of rehab and get back on her feet if
she can come
home would giving her the supplements I
I know she's on U the medicine she's on
eloquest Metropolol amlodipine and
losartan and I talked to Ben fuches last
week he said maybe try to wean her off
of those because that's what's really
making her sluggish but if we take her
off the uh blood pressure medication you
know that would be the last one that
would be the last one to come off of and
when you take her off of it don't just
go
where she to
zero yeah reduce it by reduce it by 25%
see how that goes and kind of thing yeah
she missed a dose of her blood pressure
medication before she had a mini stroke
so we can't actually take her off the
medicines but if we put her I mean when
she comes back if I can give her the
supplements uh I'm just wondering if the
C calcium and the supplements and her
calcium situation is an
issue well I would make sure she's
getting plenty of vitamin D3 because she
may be you know she can be taking in all
the calcium you want but she could be
not absorbing it she could be urinating
it out if she's not getting enough
vitamin D3 to hold it in the body okay
and plant it in the bones so make sure
she's getting we have a wonderful
vitamin
D3 I take three of those twice a day
okay so you I only weigh a
one what 138 kind of thing now 140
say okay now should I keep her on the uh
the classic tablet and the rebound and
the Bone and Joint pack oh absolutely
okay okay because Ben was saying put her
on the Healthy Start pack I don't know
which the healthy store pack is included
in the pack that Dr wallik recommended
so but I include the others with it yeah
so question for Dr wck about this Dr wck
when the body's not absorbing calcium
isn't there a certain part of the body
that actually tells or controls that
calcium
absorption yeah of course that's the uh
the bones of course how about the p is
it the pituitary
gland I don't think
so yeah it's
bones um have have to do with it and
um it's one of those things where uh
even the pancreas might have a little
bit of something to do with the calcium
being absorbed and and so forth but any
rate it's one of those things where
um you know if she's eating bread or
crackers or cookies or potato chips or
pancakes or waffles and muffins
and um spaghetti and all that kind of
stuff her her Villi are dead and she
cannot absorb stuff
when you can't absorb stuff you lose it
your your liver takes it out of the rest
of your body and uses it and then
flushes it out of the
body all right thank you so much Dr
wallik and we are at the end of our
Showtime with you our time I know your
time is precious and we appreciate every
moment that we get with you so thank you
thank you thank you Dr wallik for
another great show well thank you Becca
and thank you team and thank you all of
our col
we really really appreciate you and
respect you for wanting to you know ask
for some outside information and you
know just keep in touch with us because
sometimes it takes a little bit to heal
those intestines you know stop getting
rid of you know get rid of all the bad
stuff and it might take you a month to
regrow those Villa it might take you two
months depending on how long you've been
on the bad foods it might take you two
months to regrow the vill so you can
absorb the
nutrition that's correct well if I can
get my co-host on the screen with me Dr
Wall we will see you next week I know
that you've got lots of things going on
including writing that new book um that
I'm excited to be part of and get
available to the
world thanks doc thank you thank you
thank you yeah it's gonna be a lot of
fun when this one comes out because
again it's like um the
um gluc
yeah it's like it's all in your head
yeah well it's like the book is all on
your head it's one of those things where
um we we you know um the
uh the disease where the mothers were
supposed to be laying on the babies the
muscular distopy the cystic brosis all
those
things it took me like a year to go
through all that and figured out
and they fired
me for figuring out what what was
causing all these things instead of
giving an award they fired me said well
you're out of your mind
okay well I'm glad you're out of your
mind and I'm glad that you didn't let
them stop you Dr wck to continue this
folks you can find Dr wallick's books at
drj wall.com that is drj wall.com for
all of Dr
Publications so see you next week doc
okay thank you so much Becca thank you
team for everything we love you all and
let's go help some more people God bless
yes sir we are taking on your command
thank you
Doc and if I could just
have a brief moment to say thank you to
my team as they do so much around the
clock around the clock we have have our
we almost have round o'clock phone team
right now so we're excited to be able to
offer that with Albert coming online on
that phone
team um and I just want to thank the
person that has been so instrumental in
keeping us
organized as a team making sure that we
stay on task and that is my dear friend
and chosen sister Ruth Ellen who is our
executive production manager so thank
you Ruth sellen for doing that I will
also want to thank the assistant to the
executive production manager who has
been instrumental in getting this
program on all of the different
platforms and
Beyond including TV so dugs TV is a
platform right AJ thank you so much AJ
for all that you do and getting that
newsletter out also to our listeners and
if you'd like to be part of our
email
newsletter uh subscribers that's the
word go to daily withth do.com and you
will find the option to sign up for our
email list and also can submit questions
there too and then Albert thank you for
being with us I know it's in the middle
of the night for you um but coming and
making sure that people are getting into
the show in a timely manner and keeping
an eye on those um videos
make sure everybody is staying on task
and I cannot and I'm it's last but
definitely not least we have our Marilyn
who we uh lovingly consider fingers as
she does such a great job on the
transcription of what is being said
within the program putting that into the
live Zoom chat so if you are interested
in getting that information you have to
be here with us she does a great job of
typing that up and allowing it to be
available so that if you're here with us
you can do a screenshot take a picture
of it with your camera and then get with
the person that shared this program with
you and say okay this is what Dr wallik
just recommended for either myself or
someone who has similar conditions that
I am experiencing can you help me get it
and absolutely they will be happy to get
that for you so again get back with the
person that shared this program with you
if there is no one to thank and you have
not been in communication with anybody
about Dr wck or youngevity or the
products or pharmacist Ben feel free to
go to daily withth
do.com daily withd do.com we do have a
full store there or get in contact with
one of our health coaches make sure that
you're choosing the things right for you
based on Dr wallik teachings at 855
3377 my name is Becca Dukes as the
hostess of this program a lead trainer
for the daily with Doc team and critical
Health newsletter team and The Institute
of holistic health trainer and director
of student
services I want to commend you for
taking this time investing in
yourself because not many people will
take an hour to learn about what they
can do to empower themselves so share
this information with your family with
your communities and together we really
can make a difference in this world bye
for
[Music]
now
oh
[Music]
o
oh
[Music]
to
la
[Music]
oh
h
[Music]
la
p
[Music]
oh
oh oh